let's go to lucca
luco's playing basketball okay clippers
forward
montreal's herald apologize to luca for
calling the math star
a bitch-ass white boy while they play
the game okay and they were fine again
into each other's face and the next
thing he apologized
the nba doesn't suspend or do anything
now here's a question
if if luca called
harold the n-word what does the nba do
so you got [ __ ] ass white boy versus n
word
[ __ ] ass white boy doesn't get you
suspended what does the n word do to
luca
if he did that in the playoffs i don't
know i'm i'm actually asking inward
you're that you're can i mean talk about
cancel call would you be successful
would you be suspended for sure for sure
how many games
uh you use the n-word in an nba white
guy
not a not a black to black okay white
white guy two black guy
oh yeah you're suspended for sure okay
what do you think about this you played
basketball
before yeah how is this is this you know
normal stuff where
it's okay both ways or it's not
acceptable okay so number one i've
played basketball my whole life i played
high school i played a little bit in
college a little bit of semi-pro i
played
do you know how many times i've been
called a bitch-ass white boy how many
times
infinite infinite amount to the point
where it just rolls off my skin
and i would beat black guys all the time
and i would be like what's up buddy you
know
check ball you know no big deal but
unfortunately it is
par it is a double standard a white guy
you know
a lot of times when i would play i mean
i would play in downtown miami and i
would sometimes be the only white guy on
the court
and if a white goes yeah if a black guy
is like all right like i got the white
boy
you know it's par for the course
there's no way in hell that i'm gonna
come out like all right i got the the
bitch-ass black guy on my
like you don't even say that you're not
looking for drama
there is a double standard it is what it
is unfortunately
but now in today's climate in today's
culture where blm
there's literally black lives matter on
the on the court
you know you've got riots you've got
great yeah it's so much drama going on
everything is so heightened everything
is so
hyper sensitive you just can't say [ __ ]
like that
on tv mantras harold now if you go to
any public park
yeah any any hoop any court i guarantee
you
that is being said non-stop [ __ ] ass
white boy this that the other
and you know what i don't even know if
it's that racist i think it's just part
of
just kind of part of the basketball
culture unfortunately but
i think it took something like this for
people to be like hold on
black guys can say it but white guys
can't but maybe not it's not so
you know you saw what jason williams the
former duke point guard said about it he
came out and he says
damn tres like damn my tres this this
ain't cool they think you can't be doing
stuff like that
so good for him yeah no no that guy's
that guy's a sharp dude right there um
if you want if you want to
if you want to play that's how good it's
it's how long is that buck 52 we don't
have that kind of time
so first of all what do you think about
this oh is it in the first 10 first 10
seconds play the first 10 seconds
but damn trez damn mantras
i can only imagine if luka doncic had
said something like that to you
and they got caught on tape
i can only imagine during black lives
matter how much of a big deal
that would have been considering today's
climate
and state good voice of reason right
there
okay good for him michael what do you
think no and you know it
with what we're going through right now
i mean you know we keep pointing out
differences
you know uh if we just stop pointing out
the differences i don't think we're
gonna have it i think he was way off and
i think something needs to be done about
it because the fact of the matter is
you're talking about it happens on the
basketball court
basketball court is a bunch of imitation
of what happens on a professional
basketball court
you know what i mean because that's when
you're playing the game it's what you
want to be i mean you know when you're a
kid you
you even pick a player and make
everybody call you that while you're
playing you know
so you know it's an imitation of what
you see there so i think it's you know i
think he needs to be a better leader i
mean when you take that job
it comes with it so i think something
needed to be done i don't want to talk
about the double standard because
i think there's two different issues
here's what i will say here's what i
will say to bring some positivity to
this
let's see it if you want to talk about
luka doncic you know he is
he is not a bitch-ass white boy he is a
bad ass
mofo white boy that kid is bad he just
hit a game winner over the clippers
no question there's i mean i think when
all is said and done i mean this is a
little forward thinking you know
nostradamus over here
he might be better than larry bird
at the end of his career he might be i
know you're a huge larry bird fan i know
you're a
huge larry bird fan but damn the kids
got game so respect to
to luca i know he's here in dallas doing
his dancing thing
let me tell you he's a stud good for
cuban and uh and dallas maps to have a
guy like him and
you've got his rookie card on i do
actually have many of them
10 of them